josé c'est mon fils c'est lui qui fait
les skis pour le suédois
justement d un suédois h m ces signaux
ouais mais c'est génial
bonjour tout le monde je te voilà tu as
une seule religion qui fait pas il s'est
blessé
non nous on les fait pas avec lui je
suis en faillite la boîte est en train
de couler selon mr johansson ton père
est algérien
ouais tu vas faire les jeux olympiques
pour l'algérie en ski de fond les jeux
olympiques un algérien sur des skis mais
c'est moins une fois mieux car suédois
voilà ça je vais t'expliquer il va faire
les jeux olympiques en ski de fond non
mais rassure toi pour l'algérie
moi j'y crois à mort il parle même pas
arabe matthew mc les six mois mais il ya
pas besoin de parler arabe pour faire du
ski y voit la raison pour qualifier il
faut que tu fasses des courses de coupe
du monde des courses de coupe du monde
oui je te sens fébrile là avec steph on
a tout misé dans la boîte au jour d'hui
ce qu'on vous demande c'est juste un
petit effort jusqu'au jo
réveille-toi sam tu fais une heure 27
sors ton délire l'a appelée lâcher des
algériennes pour la subvention
jack cust en quatre mois on n'a plus une
thune et mon mec passe ses journées à
faire du ski en attendant d'être au
chômage mais tu vois pas les
conséquences que ça autour de toi t'es
quoi je vais aller en algérie
je vais aller voir la fédération vous
allez avoir la tenue officielle de
l'équipe nationale
peut-être monsieur mais moi j'ai besoin
de 20 mille dollars a pas 2020 me
famille
avec tam et rangez pas pu en au travail
coûte un kobe pour que le seuil est le
choix
aide-moi qualifier l'algérie pour les
jeux olympiques
le code l'intérieur
tu fait reculer là
tourner en rond là ça c'est un peu le
principe du ski de fond tu vois ton nom
seif faut qu'on leur parle court du
rexall lambert johnson regarde ça